este es uno de los grupos de personas
reunidos en el centro de la ciudad de
buenos aires- para marchar hacia la casa
rosada de la casa de gobierno en
argentina en respaldo a la
vicepresidenta cristina fernández de
kirchner y en repudio al intento de
asesinato que tuvo lugar el jueves por
la noche en la puerta de su domicilio
justamente para facilitar este tipo de
manifestaciones aquí en otros puntos del
país el presidente alberto fernández
declaró el feriado nacional este día
viernes a su vez la justicia está
avanzando en la investigación de lo
ocurrido tomando declaraciones a
testigos haciendo los peritajes
correspondientes
seguramente también interrogando al
hombre que intentó asesinar a la
vicepresidenta cristina fernández de
kirchner la gran pregunta sigue siendo
porque porque este intento de asesinato
además en este contexto de este día que
ha cambiado los planes de todos una
reunión de gabinete de emergencia y tal
vez tendremos nuevos anuncios a lo largo
del día vinculados con la investiga y
con decisiones de gobierno